there's an interesting piece in the
Chicago Tribune by rekhs hockey which
points out just like a very basic but
poignant relevant question about Brett
Kavanaugh sexual assault accuser which
is so simple it's almost stupid but it's
not stupid
if she's the one lying why does she want
to full-on thorough investigation
right like if she were lying wouldn't
she be worried that a full and thorough
investigation would expose the fact that
she's lying and even more so especially
since most likely Brett Kavanaugh is
going to be confirmed regardless of what
happens at next week's hearing about the
alleged sexual assault why would she
want to even participate in these
hearings which are going to lead to her
enduring months if not years of smearing
from the right merely for speaking out
given that Brett Kavanaugh will likely
be confirmed either way if the story
wasn't true and in the same way that 65
women or some such number came out of
the woodwork to say that Cavanaugh is
just a great guy Kristine Blasi Ford has
also had endless people come forward and
say she wouldn't make this stuff up she
wouldn't come forward now if this wasn't
true and her therapist notes matched
this story and every element of this
seems to indicate that she's not going
to just make this up out of thin air and
I sympathize with this thought process
if Cavanaugh were truly the innocent
Catholic school choirboy that he claims
to be he should want the full and
thorough investigation and it's Ford who
should be scared of an actual
investigation because if she's lying the
lies might get exposed and there's
actually a pattern here that matches
that of the Trump Russia investigation
if Trump was innocent and I said this
all along he'd say do the investigation
I'm president I've got a lot to do I'll
cooperate otherwise I'll stay out of the
way I'll be cleared and that's it that's
the most direct path to the truth if
Brett Kavanaugh were innocent he'd say
let's do a full investigation and
hearings and anything you want because
I'm obviously going to be
but it's not Cavanaugh who wants that
it's Ford who wants her claims examines
its examined its Ford who wants her
allegations to be heard she wants
investigators to dig deeply into what
she's alleging and like wrecks up key
says in his Chicago Chicago Tribune
piece when someone makes outrageous
claims they don't say investigate this
as fully as possible when someone makes
claims that they believe are not exactly
true or spurious or deceptive they don't
say let's do as many hearings as you
want and get as many federal
investigators looking into this because
any normal person knows that they're
going to get caught and as I told you
earlier this week the hearings are being
held to get hearings on the record and
Republicans can then say hey listen we
did it it's he said she said in the end
Kavanagh is good to go on to the Supreme
Court for life so even further
Ford must know this and the idea that
knowing that this is most likely the way
it's going to go she would put lies in
such a central and publicly viewable
place doesn't make any sense and by the
way we learned that the potential
witness to the sexual assault isn't even
going to be questioned or part of the
hearing his name's Marc judge he told
the committee he just doesn't want to
testify this is an appointment for life
to the Supreme Court for Brett Kavanaugh
subpoena Marc judge and get him in there
right like there's you've got a witness
here and that's another reason why it
doesn't seem to me as though Christine
ballsy Ford is lying she specifically
says hey there's this other person who
was there and that person has no
interest in showing up and if she's
lying could say I wasn't there this
woman's lying if he truly wasn't a
witness if he truly wasn't involved he
would show up and say that and if he
wasn't there it would be insanely risky
for Christine Blasi Ford to claim that
Marc judge was there because an
investigation that's serious any kind of
deep probing into this
could turn up that she made that up too
but she wants it investigated so bottom
line if she's lying about the incident
if she's lying about mark judges
presence there that would be uncovered
by an investigation period if
Republicans think she's lying
they should also demand a full
investigation so that they can clear
Brett Kavanaugh but they aren't what
Republicans want is to get Brett
Kavanaugh confirmed as quickly as
possible get among the court for life
they've reluctantly agreed to postpone
the confirmation to have the sort of
weakest and lamest of all hearings and
that's the reality here that if the
situation were that Brett Kavanaugh knew
he was innocent and Christine Blasi Ford
was making this up she wouldn't want a
full and thorough investigation but
Brett Kavanaugh would am I missing
something here please let me know your
thoughts i'm on twitter at des Pakman
and the show is on twitter at david
pakman show today's program sponsored in
part by Blink is comm slash Pakman I've
talked about blinkers before it's this
awesome app that I've been using for
several months now and what it does is
take the best and most critically
acclaimed non-fiction books and
condenses them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to in one sitting
you could listen to ten books in an
afternoon I know that many in our
audience want to expand their horizons
and learn more about all sorts of
different topics but we're mostly
limited by time to some degree I know
I'm not able to read all of the books
that I want simply because I've got
other stuff going on and that's why
blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to be li NK is t-dot-com slash
AAK ma n